THE POLITICAL PHILOSOPHER, ONE
OF THE GREATEST THINKERS ABOUT
OF THE INTENT AUTHORITARIAN
TIZZY HIM SAID THE POLITICAL
LEFT ALWAYS GOES TO MOTIVE,
ALWAYS ARGUES THAT ITS
OPPONENTS ARE NOT JUST WRONG
BUT EVIL.
REMEMBER THAT, IT'S
IMPORTANT.
WE KEEP BEING TOLD THAT THE
KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION PROCESS
HAS FURTHER INTENSIFIED
AMERICA'S POLITICAL
POLARIZATION.
FOR WHICH BLAME LIES ON BOTH
SIDES.
AS I SAID LAST WEEK, I CAN'T
STAND ARTISAN SHIP AND HOPE TO
BUILD ACROSS PARTY MOVEMENT
BEHIND THE IDEAS OF POSITIVE
POPULISM BUT RIGHT NOW AT THIS
MOMENT, ONE PARTY STANDS IN
THE WAY OF THAT WITH ITS
EXTREMISM, HATE AND RAGE.
NO IT IS NOT BOTH SITES.
IT IS ONE SIDE.
YOU HAVE NEVER HEARD A
REPUBLICAN LEADER TALK ABOUT
DEMOCRATS LIKE THIS.
>> HE HAS BEEN RACIST, HE HAS
BEEN SEXIST, HE'S BEEN
ISLAMOPHOBIC, HE HAS BEEN
ANTI- LGBTQ, THERE'S A LONG
LIST.
I DON'T THINK IT'S USEFUL TO
SAY WE FIGURED IT OUT, THIS IS
WHAT HE IS, HE HAS A VIEW OF
AMERICA THAT IS INCREDIBLY
CONSTRICTIVE.
HE TALKED ABOUT AMERICA, HE
TALKS TO THEM ALL THE TIME,
AND IF BY NO MEANS THE
MAJORITY, AS WE KNOW, BUT IT
IS A VERY HARD-CORE ARE
RESPONDING TO HIM AND
SUPPORTING HIM.
>> STATUS AMERICA.
HONESTLY.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN A REPUBLICAN
SENATOR SAY ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
>> PLEASE, GET UP IN THE FACE
OF SOME CONGRESSPEOPLE.
>> WHAT EXACTLY DOES A
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTATIVE EVER
DO THIS.
>> DO YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM
THAT CABINET IN A RESTAURANT
AND THE APARTMENT OR GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT.
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU TELL THEM THEY'RE NOT
WELCOME.
>> THESE DAILY SCENES OF
MAYHEM AND VIOLENCE, HOW MANY
OF THOSE HATE FILLED FACES ARE
CONSERVATIVE?
IF NOT BOTH SIDES, IS ONE
SIDE.
IT'S ONE SIDE THAT STARTED THE
CYCLE OF HATE AND NO IT WAS
NOT MITCH MCCONNELL BLOCKING
MAREK GARLAND.
HERE'S THE SENATOR WHO FIRST
STATED NO SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE SHOULD BE APPOINTED IN
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEAR.
>> PRESIDENT BUSH SHOULD
CONSIDER FOLLOWING THE
PRACTICE OF A MAJORITY OF HIS
PREDECESSORS AND NOT NAME A
NOMINEE UNTIL AFTER THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION IS COMPLETED.
>> HERE'S THE SENATOR WHO
ENDED THE 60 VOTE WILL A
BUST OR RULE WHO ENDED
BIPARTISANSHIP.
>> CHANGE THE RULE REGARDING
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE WILL
APPLY EQUALLY TO BOTH PARTIES
AND REPUBLICANS ARE IN POWER,
THESE CHANGES WILL APPLY TO
THEM JUST AS WELL SPREAD THAT
MR. PRESIDENT IS SIMPLE
FAIRNESS
FIRNESS
FAINESS
FAIRNSS
FAIRNESS.
>> SIMPLE FAIRNESS.
HERE'S THE SENATOR WHO
THROUGHOUT CENTURIES OF
BIPARTISAN ADVISING CONSENT
TRADITION AND VOWED TO BLOCK A
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE WITHIN
HOURS OF ITS ANNOUNCEMENT
BEFORE A SINGLE SECOND OF
TESTIMONY, BEFORE A SINGLE
CASE HAD BEEN REVIEWED.
>> I WILL OPPOSE HIM WITH
EVERYTHING I'VE GOT.
>> AND NOW, WHO'S ESCALATING
THE ARMS RACE OF HATE.
LAST TIME I LOOKED, THIS MAN
WAS A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, NOT A REPUBLICAN.
>> I BELIEVE OUR PARTY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MUST BE A
PARTY THAT FIGHTS FIRE WITH
FIRE.
WHEN THEY GO LOW I SAY WE HIT
HARDER.
>> SURE ENOUGH, THE LEFT ARE
NOW SAYING JUSTICE KAVANAUGH
MUST BE IMPEACHED OR THE
SUPREME COURT PACKED.
WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT LATER
IN THE SHOW, BECAUSE HE'S TOO
POLITICAL BUT I DON'T REMEMBER
CONSERVATIVES CALLING FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT OF JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBURG OVER THIS.
>> I CAN IMAGINE WHAT THIS
PLACE WOULD BE, I CAN IMAGINE
WHAT THE COUNTRY WOULD BE WITH
DONALD TRUMP IS OUR
PRESIDENT.
SAID THE JUSTICE COME OUT FOR
THE COUNTRY IT COULD BE FOUR
YEARS.
FOR THE COURT IT COULD BE, I
DON'T EVEN WANT TO CONTEMPLATE
THAT.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR US TO MOVE
TO NEW ZEALAND.
AND IT'S NOT THAT SUPPOSED
AUTHORITARIAN, THAT GREAT
UNDERMINING OF DEMOCRATIC
NORMS DONALD TRUMP CALLING FOR
PACKING OF THE COURT, IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS.
YES WE ARE IN POLARIZED TIMES,
BUT NO IT IS NOT BOTH SIDES.
CONSERVATIVE ACADEMIC, HOWEVER
MUCH THEY DISAGREE WITH
LIBERALS SIMPLY DON'T TALK
LIKE THIS LEFT-WING PROFESSOR
AT GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY.
LOOK AT THIS COURSE OF
ENTITLED WHITE MEN JUSTIFYING
IT SERIAL RAPIST ENTITLEMENT.
ALL OF THEM DESERVE MISERABLE
DEPTHS WHILE FEMINIST LAUGH AS
THEY TAKE THEIR LAST GASP.
BONUS.
WE CASTRATE THEIR CORPSES AND
FEED THEM TO SWINE.
BY THE WAY, THAT'S NOT EVEN
REMARKABLE ANYMORE.
REMEMBER, KATHY GRIFFIN,
REMEMBER SNOOP DOGG, AND NOW,
A NEW LOW AS THE LOONY LEFT
DRAGS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
INTO THE GUTTER.
SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS, WHO
OVER 21 YEARS IN THE SENATE
HAS SPONSORED 28 BILLS ON
SEXUAL VIOLENCE, WHO HAS BEEN
AN OUTSPOKEN CHAMPION FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS, WHO EVEN AS
SHE VOTED ON BRETT KAVANAUGH
SPOKE POWERFULLY ABOUT HER
HOPE THAT THE CONFIRMATION
PROCESS WOULD LEAD TO MORE
JUSTICE FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIMS THAN DECENT,
THOUGHTFUL, SINCERE WOMEN
WOULD DESCRIBED BY THE WOMEN'S
MARCH AS A RAPE APOLOGIST.
THE WOMEN'S MARCH IS NOT A
FRINGE ORGANIZATION.
IT'S ENDORSED BY COUNTLESS
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
THEY OWN THAT.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP ALLOWED
THE POPULIST MOVEMENT TO BE
TAINTED BY THE NEO-NAZIS OF
CHARLOTTESVILLE, I SPOKE OUT
AGAINST IT ON THIS NETWORK, ON
THE SHOW.
WHERE ARE YOU KAMALA HARRIS,
CORY BOOKER AND ALL THE OTHER
SELF RIGHTEOUS HYPOCRITES WHO
CONSTANTLY LECTURE THE REST OF
US.
WILL YOU SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THIS HATE?
IF YOU DON'T CONDEMN IT YOU
ARE PART OF IT.
OF COURSE THEY WON'T CONDEMN
IT BECAUSE HATE IS THE LEFT'S
CURRENCY.
HATE IS THEIR ENERGY.
HATE IS THERE PATH TO POWER.
JUST AS HANER SAID, THE XENA
PHOBIA MEANS SUSPICION AND
HATRED OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIFFERENT, IT'S A VERY
DEFINITION OF THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEIR BRAND IS HATE AND IF
THEY WIN, IT WILL GET WORSE.
NOVEMBER IS COMING THEY
CHANTED ON THE STEPS OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
YES IT IS.
SO LET'S USE IT TO SHOW THE
DIVISIVE DESTRUCTIVE DEMOCRATS
THAT EXTREMISM, HATE AND RAGE
WILL NOT WIN IN AMERICA.
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU THINK OF
THAT AT HILTON NEXT AND NEXT
REVOLUTION.
WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT IT?
>> I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
THIS UNIQUE GIFT WHERE HE
PUSHES PEOPLE TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY UNMASKED THEMSELVES
AND THEY SHOW WHO THEY REALLY
ARE.
I THINK WE SAW THAT WITH THE
LEFT, THERE IS NO LOW LOW
ENOUGH FOR THE LEFT, THEY WERE
PERFECTLY WILLING TO DESTROY
AN INNOCENT MAN IN THE NAME OF
POLITICS OR POLITICAL
RESTITUTION AND THERE WAS NO
LOW ENOUGH.
WE KNOW THEY WEAPONIZE THESE
BASELESS ALLEGATIONS.
WE KNOW SENATE DEMOCRATS WENT
OUT AND TRIED TO FIND ACCUSERS
ABOUT THE NEW YORKER PIECE
WHICH, MIND YOU, EVEN AFTER
INTERVIEWING SOMETHING LIKE 70
PEOPLE, NOT A SINGLE PERSON
CAME FORWARD TO CORROBORATE
DEBORAH RIMER'S STORY.
YET THE LEFT RAN WITH IT.
AND IT DIDN'T MATTER TO THEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DISTINCTLY
SAID THIS THAT YOU DON'T GET A
MATCH TO AN ARSONIST AND YOU
DON'T GIVE POWER TO A
LEFT-WING ANGRY MOB PARODY
THING AMERICANS ARE SITTING
BACK RIGHT NOW AFTER
WITNESSING THIS PROCESS AND
REALIZING HOW DANGEROUS THE
LEFT REALLY IS.
>> AND HERE'S THE IMPORTANT
PART, WE AS CONSERVATIVES
ALWAYS TRY TO APPEAL TO THE
BETTER ANGELS OF DEMOCRATS.
WE PROBABLY HAVE A LOT TO
AGREE ON, WE JUST HAVE
DIFFERENT WAY TO GET THERE.
WERE DONE WITH THAT.
THESE PEOPLE DO NOT WANT
WHAT'S BEST FOR THIS COUNTRY,
THEY WANT POWER.
THEY WANT THIS PRESIDENT
IMPEACHED AND PUT IN PRISON.
I'M SICK AND TIRED OF SAYING
DEMOCRATS WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR
AMERICA.
THEY DON'T.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN THE
AMERICA OF FREE SPEECH AND
FREE MARKET AND AGREE TO
DISAGREE.
THEY WANT POWER AND THEY WANT
TO DESTROY ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH THEM.
THAT IS NOT A LIBERAL VALUE,
THAT OF THE LEFTIST VALUE.
THERE'S A DISTINCTION THERE
AND WE, AS A DECENT MINDED
PEOPLE HAVE TO KEEP THEM THE
MORAL HIGH GROUND.
>> I THINK IT'S FIGHTING BACK,
BUT LET'S REMEMBER, THE PARTY
ITSELF IS WHAT'S BEEN PUSHED
SO FAR TO THE LEFT, ABANDONING
THE AVERAGE DEMOCRAT.
THIS IS WHAT I WOULD SUBMIT.
IN FACT YOU ARE CORRECT.
THERE'S NOT TWO SIDES DOING
THIS BUT I CONTEND THE COUNTRY
ITSELF IS NOT DIVIDED.
YOU HAVE 200 PEOPLE FIGHTING
OUT FROM THE SUPREME COURT,
THAT IS NOT A MASS MOVEMENT.
AS WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
SHOCKED, SO ARE WOMEN WHO
MIGHT BE DEMOCRATS WHO MAY BE
ARE NOW IDENTIFYING AS
INDEPENDENTS, LOOKING AT THAT
THINKING THIS IS NOT A REAL
ALTERNATIVE TO WHAT'S GOING
ON, AND BESIDES, THINGS ARE
GOING WELL, WHO ARE THESE
PEOPLE, AND THERE REPRESENTED
AND THEN LEADERSHIP.
THERE'S NO ONE IN LEADERSHIP
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SAYING FORCEFULLY THIS IS
ACCEPTABLE BECAUSE THEY'VE
LOST CONTROL OF THAT DYNAMIC.
I ALSO SUGGEST THAT THE POLLS
THAT WE SEE, WE KNOW THE
ENTHUSIASM VOTES, IT WOULD BE
A MISTAKE TO SUGGEST THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE RESPONDING
POSITIVELY TO WHAT THIS IS AND
SO, IF I TELL MY RADIO
AUDIENCE AND I WOULD TELL
EVERYONE WATCHING THIS, HAVE
FAITH IN YOUR NEIGHBOR.